una bolsa tiene más bolas verdes que
bolas azules y tiene al menos una bola
azul digamos que representa el número de
bolas azules y g representa el número de
bolas verdes compare a las expresiones
2b y demás g cual enunciado es correcto
aquí nos están mostrando varias
comparaciones entre 2 b y b más g
tenemos mayor que menor que o igual o no
existe suficiente información y como
siempre pausa en el vídeo y traten de
encontrar la respuesta correcta por su
cuenta
vamos a resolver esto juntos primero
veamos qué información nos están dando
nos dicen que una bolsa tiene más bolas
verdes que bolas azules podemos traducir
esto al lenguaje matemático el número de
bolas verdes es mayor que el número de
bolas azules también nos dicen que
tenemos al menos una bola azul y si
traducimos esto el lenguaje matemático
tenemos al menos uno pero quizá tengamos
más por lo que ve es mayor o igual a 1
ahora veamos si podemos manipular esto
para ver si alguna de estas opciones se
cumple hay varias maneras en las que
podemos resolver esto y quizá ustedes se
encuentren una forma diferente a la que
voy a emplear aquí pero la que se me
ocurre es que ya sea que g es mayor que
b y se agregó b en ambos lados de esta
desigualdad del lado derecho tendré b
más g y del lado izquierdo tendré b más
b y esto de aquí es 2 b
y de esta manera sé que puedo mantener
la desigualdad si estoy agregando lo
mismo en ambos lados si sumo o restó la
misma cantidad en ambos lados de la
desigualdad no la voy a cambiar así que
con esto podemos deducir que ve más g va
a ser mayor que demás b o 2 b y esto es
todo lo que necesitamos hacer ahora
veamos cuál de estas opciones coincide
con esto todas estas tienen 2 b del lado
izquierdo así que vamos a dejar aquí el
2 b del lado izquierdo de la desigualdad
y nos queda que 2 b es menor que ve más
g y esto coincide con esta opción de
aquí